the table below shows solar panel
installations by state during the fir
last fiscal year
how many total solar panels will were
installed
were installed last year in wyoming
so we look at the states so this right
over here is wyoming and this whole
table is about solar installations by
states during the last year so this is
the wyoming during the last year this is
the first quarter so the first three
months the second three months the third
quarter the fourth quarter and this
right over here is the total number of
solar panels that were installed in
wyoming last year which is what i think
they're asking us for so let's just type
that in 104.
we've got it right let's do another one
the table below indicates the points
scored by four players in a charity
basketball game how many points did ben
have in total so here's ben right over
here it's broken down by quarter but we
care about his total number of points
which is 31. so ben had a total of 31
points
so this indicates the point scored by
four players in a charity basketball
game again how many points did vanessa
score in the fourth quarter so let's
look at this is vanessa and we care
about the fourth quarter
so she scored four points in the fourth
quarter
put four right over there
all right so once again we're talking
about solar in solar panel installations
by state during the last fiscal year how
many solar panels were installed in
alabama in the second quarter in q2 so
alabama in the second quarter so that's
this right over here 28 28 solar panels
were installed so 28
so this is once again in a charity game
how many points did kevin score in the
third quarter so kevin in the third
quarter he scored nine
nine points
maybe one more just for fun
so how many points did gabriella score
in the third quarter well same idea
gabriella third quarter she scored five
points